i was um
standing with you and fred at the grammy
party last week
was it what was that was it over the
weekend sounds like last week
it was sunday it was sunday or sunday
and uh
amen
tossing around doing albums and you guys
were like let's do it and then ghazi was
sitting right there and he's like let's
go
it looked like it was gonna happen and i
was like yo guys let's go
i think freddie gibbs benny the butcher
y'all gotta do the ep
right i feel like between you two and
conway
you guys are the the hardest rappers on
the planet at the moment
it's only natural that you and you and
fred have such a crazy [ __ ] chemistry
yes we do yes we do i feel like it's
gonna happen i feel like it's gonna
happen
and i mean you guys have officially
talked about it
like several times several times but
that was the best talk right there you
saying you seen the best one that felt
like that felt like it was about to
happen tomorrow
fred was sauced up he was in that pink
suit he was in his [ __ ] there was red
bottoms he was drunk as [ __ ] he was
destined to nellie bro he was dancing to
nelly yeah freddy kane man that's freddy
king yeah so so that's something we
might be able to look forward to
man i hope so i hope so i'm gonna i'm
gonna go tap back in about that but
we're gonna see
that'll be great i think if you guys do
that you gotta do
you got to work with one producer on it
i don't know
i don't know who it is or or a derringer
we picked alcohol missed that night
we even picked producers that night
alchemist real [ __ ] alchemist freddie
benny album ep i just need six joints
that's
all even i'll take four if i'm keeping
it a buck
hey i say about eight a to be nice